by contraire sur des business
nicolas doze accueille les experts avec
jean marc jancovici il est président de
the shift project il est également
associé de carbone 4 un cabinet
d'accompagnement des entreprises
notamment pour participer mais gagner
avec cette transition énergétique a
signé de nombreux ouvrages le dernier
étant dormez tranquilles jusqu'en 2100
et autre malentendu soit le climat et
l'énergie publié chez odile jacob
gilles legendre prédateurs d'explora &
company ej ans d'intelligence et de
communication stratégique
ludovic subran chef économiste d'euler
hermes il y a deux sur twitter qui me
dit monsieur subra bien recadrer le
débat pourquoi ne rien à bouffer mon
sens ou du circo médiatique ridicule
aujourd'hui autour du co2 juste avant de
marquer une pause jean marc jancovici
j'ai essayé de rappeler les grands
enjeux de cette com - terrain telles que
vous les trouverez dans toute la presse
qui vous faire le questions réponses
pourquoi comment
j'ai l'impression depuis dix minutes on
parle d'autre chose on dit que c'est
globalement tant que chacun ne se
sentira pas touché dans sa chair et son
business il se passera rien et que c'est
pas la coop 21 que chacun va se seront
qui a touché dans sa chair et son
business et c'est normal c'est pas fait
pour ça alors si je peux être un tout
petit peu taquin droite est un tout
petit plat les liens le premier
responsable du cirque médiatique ces
médias je veux dire c'est pas non mais
attendez l'armé un revolver sur la tempe
en disant vous êtes obligés de parler de
ça donc bon mal de la quantité
enfin bondissant l'otan les autoroutes
fermées presque de la coop 20 heures
vous savez que s'il ya un mouvement
d'amplification dans les médias donc ce
qui se passe avec la coop 21 c'est que
la coop 21 réunit des chefs d'état les
chefs d'état en particulier dans les
démocraties ont toujours tendance à
survendre ce qu'ils font est par
ailleurs dans le monde politique et
c'est dramatique
il n'y a pas de processus de
capitalisation c'est là que ce n'est pas
comme dans une entreprise où quand un
patron remplace le patron précédent sauf
à ce que vraiment l'un et piquer la
femme de l'autre risque aux y conte
celui qui arrive apprend de ce qui s'est
passé avant mais dans le fond une
politique quand vous arrivez en général
vous arrivez compte celui qui vous a
précédé dont vous n'allez pas lui
demander comment il a fait vous
commencez par faire des grandes
déclarations martiales et le jour où
world est content que vous avez promis
des bêtises à ce moment il est trop tard
pour faire marche arrière
mais bon quand la coque ne fait pas
exception à cette affaire c'est à dire
qu'on a survendu un résultat en
attachant à cette manifestation des
choses qui ne sont pas de sa compétence
donc ce qui est très important c'est que
la coop comme ça a été dit tout à
l'heure
entretiennent la flamme elle est faite
pour ça elle n'est faite que pour ça
d'accord il faut pas un acte olympiens
vert pour le climat comme un gardon le
fonds vert groupe humain il est aussi
géré par vienne laisser coincer marginal
on va prendre un exemple que vous
connaissez bien le fonds vert pour le
climat on parle de 100 milliards de
dollars par an est ce que vous savez
quels sont aujourd'hui les
investissements annuels dans l'énergie
fossile en parle de 1500 ou en a un peu
moins en dessous de 1500 milliards de
dollars et les investissements tout
court dans le monde s'est voulu rajouter
1 0 donc on est en train de parler de
quelque chose qui n'est pas à la mesure
accord du problème puisque si on veut
gérer le problème il faut changer à peu
près tous partout ce qui est plutôt une
bonne nouvelle se chercher des défis
partout mais on n'est pas en train de
parler de la bonne masse d'argent donc
c'est un truc d'amorçage donc là cela
politiquement c'est important pour
donner un signe c'est important pour
montrer qu'il ya quand même quelqu'un
quelque part qui s'occupe de choses en
comptant deux régions donc ça c'est
important ça permet de faire des
méthodes tout ça c'est important
mais à l'arrivée faut que les autres s'y
mettent aussi donc la coke c'est un
point de départ et en ayant soit dit en
passant on a payé cher le fait que à
copenhague on a fait la même erreur
2009 c'est la cop15 c'est à dire que des
gens pensaient qu'on allait y avait un
monde avant où tous les problèmes
étaient résolus et un monde d'après où
il y avait plus qu'à faire etc
c'est pas vrai c'est pas ça le mandat
les notions guillaume qu'on est en train
de contacter e mans et donc ça sera gris
comme ça a été dit tout à nos héroïnes à
mai mois ce qui lui rappelle c'est qu'il
y aura un accord c'est que ce qui fera
vraiment changer les choses c'est le
jour où il y aura ceux où finalement
c'est ces normes sociales et
environnementales qu'on utilise
aujourd'hui deviendront contraignante
mais c'est pas forcément contraignantes
et où vous identifier les gagnants de la
faire taire le jour où vous avez un
patron qui vient bomber le torse en dix
ans mais moi je suis ravi qu'il ya eu
contrainte parce que c'est ça qui fait
mon business aujourd'hui ça il faut
raconter des histoires et c'est ça qui
fait qu'il ya des gens qui vont dire à
24 comprend d'où sort ma fiche de paye
vous aime tant qu'on n'a pas dit aux
gens douceur leur fiche de paye pas à %
de la population à 50% ou à 90% de la
population
votre fiche de paye sortira dollar si on
s'occupe sérieusement du problème en
démocratie vous avancerez pas ses deux
jambes
c'est déjà ce qui est en train de se
passer maintenant vous avez énormément
d'entreprises qui prêche pour un carbone
pour un prix du carbone élevée elle
existe mais on en attendait ça c'est une
des autres révolution qui est en train
de se faire et qu'ils étaient en train
de se faire jour là
opposition nord-sud est une opposition
qui n'a plus de sens sur ce sujet là
elle est il ya des oppositions majeure
entre certains pays et d'autres pays
mais l'opposition nord-sud c'est un
vieux schémas je vous assure que ce qui
est en train de se passer aujourd'hui
est en train de faire sauter tous les
vieux schémas c'est pas pour ça qu'on
est en train de se diriger vers un
avenir radieux et tous les problèmes
sont résolus
je dis juste qu'aujourd'hui toutes les
les schémas de pensée les schémas de
gouvernance et les schémas économiques
sont en train d'être bousculée par cette
question et qu'il n'y a pas de questions
précédentes qui ait eu sur les 50 60 70
80 dernières années un impact aussi fort
c'est en train si on raisonne en termes
très macropolitique c'est à dire que le
capitalisme est en train de réaliser que
son ennemi est en lui même c'est à dire
que pendant des dents de scie pendant
deux siècles ou pendant un siècle
neuf ans dans un siècle et demi on était
sur des territoires idéologique c'est à
dire le capitalisme n'avait qu'un seul
adversaire
c'était le marxisme le communisme ça
c'était ça c'est terminé il a cru qu'il
était victorieux il s'est rendu compte
que les principales menaces qui était en
train de le saper
c'était sur son propre mode de
développement et sur sa propre manière
d'envisager sa son fonctionnement ce que
dit cadeau à ses projets de général nous
ils nous disent et c'est parce qu'il est
probablement très fort et très puissant
qui va être capable progressivement et
en appliquant ses propres logiques parce
que la logique du prix du carbone la
logique du marché qu'évoquait jean-marc
tout à l'heure c'est une logique qui
s'inscrit dans une logique de marché et
une logique de capital chatel parce que
vous avez la pensée que c'est bien le
marché qui va régler à terme mais bien
sûr qu'en pense le contraire voilà alors
on en parlera parce que c'est ce que va
donner sa voix à celles mises soit c'est
le marché politique après j'avais
toutefois que ces précieux j'aimerais
avoir l'entousiasme de gilles là-dessus
m'enfin c'est pas la vérité est enfin la
vérité on n'entendra plus parler de la
coop 21 jusqu'alors on en parle à
beaucoup plus de déficit public
on parlera beaucoup plus du prix des
matières premières on parlera beaucoup
plus du chômage etc en fait cette espèce
de micro bulles afin d' espèce de deux
micros surfing là qu'on a sur ces
histoires de clans
je suis d'accord elles sont importantes
mais qu'elle change la vision du monde
ce n'est pas vrai tu parlais du clivage
nord-sud ce n'est pas vrai c'est pas
parce que la chine se tertiary d'un
petit peu plus vite du coup est prête
maintenant à faire des intentions des
engagements sur son sur sa transition
énergétique que des pays qui sont
aujourd'hui dans des problèmes
d'atténuation des effets du changement
climatique sont pas des pays qui vont
devoir être entendus et des pays qui
vont être sous l'eau dans 30 ans il ya
des pays qui vont être sous l'eau dans
50 ans et quand vous êtes un pays riche
vous savez faire contre la hollande
quand vous êtes un pays pauvre vous ne
savez pas faire avec c'est le cas des
petites îles du pacifique
donc moi ce qui m'inquiète surtout c'est
que on regarde ça avec beaucoup de
bêtises on dit ça change de modèle etc
je suis d'accord on en train de se
rendre compte que on a des ressources
limitées que on a besoin de nouvelles
normes comptables
qu'est ce qu'on fait pour agir contre ça
rien on parle du prix du carbone en est
incapable
n'hésitez pas c'est parce qu'à paris
pendant une semaine mais il va aider le
droit d'y repasser et regarder effet
d'incitation économique il n'y a rien il
n'y a rien de structurel cia pas du
business à faire quand on tutoie les
objectifs qui est contraignant c'est à
dire comme toutes les start up un petit
peu qu'ils ont envie de faire de
l'argent pour garder un petit peu la
régulation vous tutoyer la régulation
fait de l'argent si tu fais pas l'argent
et dessus si tu fais pas de l'argent sur
des investissements qui sont un petit
peu rentable il n'y a rien derrière si
y'a pas un petit peu de fiscalité
avantageuse
il n'y a rien enfin vous regardez les
investissements dans le renouvelable
nous chérissons fait de
l'assurance-crédit jeu j'ai arrêté de
compter le nombre de faillites dans le
photovoltaïque
j'ai arrêté de compter le nombre de
faillites dans l'agriculture bio j'ai
arrêté de compter le nombre de faillites
dans les bâtiments ou les entreprises
qui travaillent dans un bâtiment hqe eu
des tu n'as plus la faute que les
taureaux quand tu n'as plus la fiscalité
avantageuse funambule incitations parce
que tu as énergies carbonées qui
particulièrement basses ba aujourd'hui
ça n'est ce pas c'est une bulle
j'y crois moi aussi mais il juste
attention aux réalités aux forces de
marché ce que je l'admets la marche est
ce que ça serait c'est uniquement à leur
ordre de marche aux devis ne supporte
pas une verte isation si tu veux
l'économie et à l'oeil à la flamme il ya
l'olympisme et du climat au bourget et
puis elle est force de marcher que
décrit ludovic subran comment est ce que
vous faites votre marché
je prends un secteur que je pense qu'il
connaît bien et qui l'assurance
l'assurance vous avez un marché car
aujourd'hui j'ai l'obligation de
m'assurer ça c'est pas du tout du marché
mon entreprise elle est assurée en
responsabilité civile on m'a pas demandé
mon avis et tant mieux quand vivre par
contre si j'ai envie de m'assurer j'ai
un certain nombre de compagnies de la
place qui propose des polices alors je
vais voir si je vous propose et c'est
donc le marché il sert à mettre de la
souplesse et de la flexibilité aux
droits d'une obligation qui elle ne
relève pas du marché qui est que j'ai
l'obligation de m'assurer est bien en ce
qui concerne le changement climatique
c'est le même attelage qu'il faut avoir
en tête c'est à dire qu'il ya des
moments où on va dire aux gens ça c'est
obligatoire par contre le mode
d'exécution de cette obligation
je le laisse dans un cadre avec de la
souplesse et des acteurs qui vont et ses
dires le marché va tout faire ça revient
à dire le marché est prévisible et si le
marché était prévisible
autour de cette table on sera tous
multimilliardaire parce que on aurait
tous d'accord s'il marche était
totalement prévisible à 10 ans a déjà
tous multimilliardaire ce qui n'est pas
le cas
en tout cas pas pour moi ou personne
donc à un moment le tout marché qui va
régler le problème j'y crois pas une
seconde
par contre que aujourd'hui on ait
commencé par gérer un vrai problème avec
des mesures qui n'étaient pas
nécessairement adaptée ça je pense que
ça c'est un vrai problème et ce qui
vient d'être décrit à savoir des
faillites ici et là parce que etc
c'était écrit dès le début c'était écrit
dès le début parce que on avait le choix
entre la mesure vraiment efficace et qui
est soutenable sur le long terme qui est
de monter le prix de ce qui pose
problème et la mesure sympa démago à
court terme qui est d'abaisser le prix
de ce qui est sympathique
la subvention malheureusement si la
subvention sur le long terme l est pas
il ya pas des grosses têtes qui viennent
en place ça tient pas donc il y avait on
a sorti avec mon associé actuelle un
livre en 2006 qui plaidait pour la mise
en place d'une taxe carbone croissante
on a dû attendre neuf ans pour que ça
arrive en france
et maintenant malheureusement sa frappe
a le job ça ira pas assez vite donc il
ya des domaines dans lesquels il faut
passer par des régulations
je vous donne un exemple mondial donc
des régulations mondiales ou européennes
on nous dit que il faut appris universel
de câbles là c'est de nouveau pareil on
a en france on est toujours dans le tout
ou rien on adore les grands soirs les
machins qui vont tout changer d'un coup
de baguette magique
moi j'y crois pas je suis beaucoup plus
anglais de ce point de vue et vous savez
comment les anglais sont sortis de
l'esclavagé ils sont sortis de l'
esclavage avec des petits machins donc
ils ont commencé par dire on continue à
avoir des esclaves mais peut-être qu'on
va pas leur mettre les fers aux pieds
quand on les cantons les transbordent
par navire bon vous auriez été contre
l'esclavagé vous auriez dit c'est pas
sérieux ce truc là il faut pas
décelables du tout en attendant ils sont
sortis de l'esclavagé plus vite que les
américains qui étaient dans une logique
de tout au rien et sans passer par une
guerre donc ce qui est important c'est
de voir où les choses sont en train de
bouger progressivement et là je suis pas
d'accord il se passe des choses
progressivement ça va pas assez vite
je suis le premier à le dire c'est pas
assez suffisait pas suffisamment mis en
lumière on continue à donner trop là le
portefeuille le voit des gens qui font
du greenwashing etc
mais oui bien sûr il y en a plein en
continuant à en avoir plein énormément
d'ambiguïté mai mais il ya quand même
des choses qui se craintes et des choses
qu'ils augmentent de manière
irréversible
ce qui est en train de se passer en ce
moment dans le monde financier il ya des
trucs qui sont en train de se tromper et
c'est irréversible ça et on reviendra
pas en arrière
encore une fois ça va pas assez vite
mais c est ce qu on est d'accord pour
moi c'est le seul truc je suis d'accord
un logiciel avec les deux points du qui
m'inquiète c'est est ce qu'on se rend
compte
collectivement qu'on est dans une
période du cycle économique que soient
les pressions déflationnistes que ce
soit le prix faibles de l'énergie
carbonées que ce soit le les problèmes
de déficit de dettes excédera pendant
lesquelles en fait on se rend on se rend
compte que ils se rendent des choses
institutionnellement ou pas d'ailleurs
c'est un petit peu un des enjeux de la
coop avec contraignant pas contraignants
les engagements pas mais qu'au final
sans réalité sans incitation si le cil
l'économie verte n'est pas une espèce de
swat filet de sécurité soit de
trampoline pour faire mieux il ya pas
moyen que ça décolle suis d'accord mais
de nature hawk ride plus je suis
d'accord qu'il manque aujourd'hui c'est
la cohérence d'ensemble c'est à dire
qu'aujourd'hui on n'a jamais eu un
patron de gouvernement ou apprentis
challandes que les autres ou un patron
de la commission
juncker qui a dit décarbonés l'économie
ça va être la colonne vertébrale et je
mets tout en cohérence donc je ne fais
pas du saupoudrage des machins ici que
je donne puis je retire je fais pas de
règle de trois pour savoir si quand je
passe du marginal au principal mon
système de subvention va continuer à
tenir
donc pour le moment c'est géré de
manière amateuriste et démago ça je suis
d'accord avec vous par contre il est
possible
il est possible de le gérer de manière
par amateuriste et des mégots et là où
je suis aussi d'accord avec vous lors
j'ai peut-être vous paraître très
oiseaux de mauvaise augure c'est que je
pense que ce plan de décarbonation de
l'économie il ne faut pas le basé sur
les surplus de la croissance parce que
je fais partie des gens qui pensent
qu'il n'y aura plus de croissance
donc non mais du coup c'est ça qui fait
toute la difficulté du problème c'est
que vous n'allez pas donner plus à
gauche sans enlever quelque chose à
droite et ça vaut aussi pour nous mêmes
c'est à dire que nous on n'aura pas plus
de tout il va falloir qu'on fasse des
choix qu'on les assume elle qu'on sache
si on veut plus de paix pour nos enfants
et un peu moins de trucs maintenant ou
si on veut linverse il va falloir qu'on
se mette d'accord avait une vraie
question est justement le risque a été
le revers de la médaille du progrès que
nous avons vécu jean tirole dit
abandonné 2% de pouvoir d'achat pour
sauver la planète c'est quand même pas
la mer à boire
le globalement si des pays comme les
nôtres et audacieux sur la mer à boire
parce qu'il va falloir savoir là parce
qu'elle aura pris 8 m en cas d'élévation
de la température de plus de 4 degrés
est ce que ça veut dire un peu de forme
de décroissance ou en tout cas de pose
le fait de devoir prendre à bras le
corps à tous les niveaux les enjeux
climatiques et de réchauffement on ya
déjà plus de plus sa révolution digitale
qui elle-même legendre est même qu'est
ce que la même ambiguïté sur la question
la productivité sur le site et sur son
impact sur la croissance c'est à dire on
a aujourd'hui deux grands sujets sur
lequel il ya un vrai débat quant à son
impact sur la croissance
la révolution digitale d'un côté
solutions climatiques de l'autre est ce
que l'écologie et la croissance mais on
y est déjà
le en fait l'europe a une chance c'est
que la décroissance on y est déjà
alors vous allez dire c'est une drôle de
chance oui j'ai dit oui on sait pas trop
la gérer connor parce qu'on est vieux on
est le dos au mur donc nous et on y est
déjà à cause justement du problème de la
contraintes d'approvisionnement en
combustibles fossiles en europe parce
qu'en europe on est déjà sous contrainte
quelque chose que les gens qui nous
écoutent ne savent peut-être pas c'est
que le maximum de la consommation
pétrolière de l'europe c'était 2006
depuis 2006 l'europe a perdu 18% de
consommation pétrolière et on l'a pas
perdu parce qu'on a fait des efforts en
volume mais parce que la croissance
affaiblies parce que on en a plus assez
parce qu'en 2005 la production mondiale
de pétrole s'arrête de croître de frais
pétrole en parle des liquides et gazeux
vrai pétrole et comme on n'est plus en
plus nombreux autour de la table de
repas et bien il y en a de moins en
moins pour les importateurs historique
dont les pays de l' ocde
donc tous les pays de l' ocde états unis
compris consomme moins de pétrole
aujourd'hui qu'en 2006 on consomme
également moins de gaz parce que la mer
du nord est passé par son pic en 2005
depuis elle décline et le gaz est une
énergie qui se transporte plus mal sur
longue distance et gazeux et donc
pétrole et gaz faisant les deux tiers de
l'approvisionnement européen
l'europe est déjà en décrue subi et
j'insiste sur le subit de combustibles
fossiles et donc la production
industrielle est en décrue suivi aussi à
part l'allemagne et quelques pays de
l'est où les pays européens sont en
décrue de production industrielle depuis
2007 touche tous la grande-bretagne la
finlande le danemark l'espagne l'italie
touche à cause de la contrainte fossiles
énergie à cause de la contrainte
énergétique
donc nous on a l'obligation d'inventer
le monde de demain tout de suite parce
que c'est de ça dont dépend le problème
du chômage tout de suite là maintenant
donc nous on a cette opportunité de
réconcilier des le problème mais ça
demande de la hauteur de vue et sa
demande là je suis tout à fait d'accord
pas des grandes rotomontades et les
grandes déclarations pendant quinze
jours et puis après on va passer à autre
chose et à l'élection de 2017 si on fait
ça on a perdu
si on se dit c'est la chance de
réinventer et je vais faire un peu de
cocorico les français sont pas mauvais
dans la réinvention globalement
historiquement la pensée des grands
systèmes complexes
c'est plutôt une force du pays donc moi
j'ai envie d'y rejetons nous là dessus
c'est notre chance et la logique sur
gilles legendre ludovic subran lésinerai
6 minutes 30
comme l'a dit jean marc c'est un sujet
qui ne peut être qu européen l'affluence
met une force d'impulsion et c'est là où
maman elle joue pas son rôle de ça alors
c'est quand les rats l'allemagne n ya
pas d'idées qui viennent et alors là
dessus et est par ailleurs l'europe
aujourd'hui ne fonctionne pas n'est pas
équipé dans sa gouvernance pour
promouvoir des projets de cette nature
cet accord aussi c'est à dire que
aujourd'hui nous tombons en france sur 1
allez dire un affaiblissement tragique
du politique et en europe sur un
affaiblissement tragique de sa
gouvernance au sort ined une
inadaptation de la gouvernance
européenne pour traiter ce genre de
sujet contre les knicks étaient tirés
d'actifs doivent de trouver une boussole
qui met tout le monde d'accord
je suis très universel de la tonne de
carbone l'urgence j'ai eu durant ce mois
j'ai une suggestion à faire louis jobard
choco vise l'europe devrait introduire
l'exception à la libre concurrence
tenez vous bien pour sauvegarde du
climat ce qui permettrait de refaire
médiate relais l'exception à la libre
concurrence entre accepter l'idée qu'un
oligopole ou un monopole régulé
c'est pas plus idiot que dans les
projets de long terme que je suis là que
c'est grâce à ça qu'on a fait
l'aéronautique le train le nucléaire est
tout un tas de trucs donc l'oligopole où
le monopole bien régulé c'est quelque
chose qui peut aussi avoir ses vertus et
par ailleurs aujourd'hui le fait qu'on
ait cette libre concurrence vous
interdit de faire des politiques
intégrées c'est à dire ça vous interdit
de dire je vais commencer par coller une
réglementation sur les voitures pour
être sûr qu'elles conçoivent en pop il
de litres au cent et en même temps je
vais m'assurer qu'elles sont bien fait
chez nous vous pouvez pas faire les deux
en même temps aujourd'hui
et moi je suis partisan qu'on fasse les
deux en même temps pour ça vous devez
inventer quelque chose qui n'existe pas
aujourd'hui dans la conception
européenne enfin dans les plans
économique européen
c'est que vous devez réconcilier les
objectifs ou réconcilier les diverses
facettes d'un même plan et ça ça suppose
le truc à mon avis le plus rapide à
faire c'est pas de dire je vais casser
la mécanique pour tous remplacés parce
que là on est parti pour vingt ans c'est
en ce qui concerne la sauvegarde
énergétiques et climatiques d'introduire
une exception aux règles en vigueur dans
vous prenez un seul sujet celui là et
vous dites sur ce sujet là j'ai droit de
transgresser les règles en vigueur
logique la france pour la cause des
saints
j'essaie de réfléchir à ce qu'il parlait
de la deuxième révolution qui est la
révolution technologique où la
révolution du numérique est derrière
cette révolution il ya l'utilisateur
contributeurs qui devient un petit peu
le centre du sujet c'est à dire chacun
veut contribuer à ce qu'ils utilisent
comme service hectares et dans le climat
ont fait exactement le contraire c'est à
dire on déresponsabilise chaque jour
davantage les gens en disant l'état va
gérer et là on parler de monopole régulé
et cédera comme solution c'est à dire on
se dit le ménage où l'entreprise est un
petit peu trop myope et donc pour
l'aider à long terme à faire les bonnes
choses aujourd'hui tu pas qu'il faut que
des monopoles jeudi il faut pas
s'interdire d'en faire bien sûr mais un
exemple je pense que derrière il ya
aussi le fonds vert pour le climat ou
les ou les incitations fiscales etc
on sent que l'état veut se
responsabiliser là dessus parce qu'il
voit plus loin que le ménage où
l'entreprise est derrière la seule façon
de vraiment remettre d'euros
responsabiliser les entreprises et les
ménages c'est cette histoire du prix
unique du carbone c'est cette histoire
du de voir comment aujourd'hui aux dés
aujourd'hui on peut regarder une
position nette de d'émissions carbone
pour savoir si on est créditeur ou
débiteur n'est dit la vie du de la
planète quoi et ça malheureusement
à la coop 21 et dans les discussions qui
ont précédé
il n'ya rien dessus oui mais il ya des
choses en marche vers il c'est à cause
de la coop 21
enfin savoir à la cause d'un dea a créé
un terreau favorable pour que par
exemple sorte 'l'indice d'euronext quand
on vient de parler la coque 21 créé un
terreau favorable pour que le gouverneur
de la banque d'angleterre est déclarée
qui est par ailleurs le président du
conseil de stabilité financière et dise
ce qu'il a dit donc évidemment
l'histoire ne s'écrit pas uniquement et
tant mieux
et tant mieux parce que ça serait encore
plus déresponsabilisant que les états
mais par contre ça crée un terreau
favorable et il vaut mieux l'avoir que
pas la voir et on peut pas et on peut
pas juger car l'histoire est plié par
contre c'est bien que des gens disent
c'est important de s'occuper du problème
j'ai levé et est aidé s'en occuper
réellement c'est vrai que les
entreprises sont encore très balbutiante
sur ce sujet mais ça commence
ça commence réellement la situation dans
le secteur de la construction est en
train de se réinventer là dessus alors
on a des problèmes sur du côté des
rénovations du côté des constructions
neuves
il se passe des choses essentielles sur
les secteurs financés y compris sur les
allocations d'actifs
la façon dont petit à petit la notation
sociale et environnementale fait son
entrée dans le mode de gestion et dont
des études extrêmement poussée montre
que des entreprises vertueuses sur le
plan environnemental sont aussi des
entreprises qui performent plutôt mieux
que les indices généraux tout ça c'est
des prises de conscience et des micros
micromarché micro-initiatives me micro
des marges qui agrégé vont finir par
donner quelque chose c'est vrai
qu'aujourd'hui on est au tout début et
que quand on voit le mur à franchir on a
l'impression qu'on y arrivera jamais
c'est pas évident que vous êtes à la
tête d'une boîte de savoir où sur les
risques ou sur les opportunités aux
cheveux gris ou est ce qu'ils savent
leur garde c'est quoi le marché a
finalement simplement simplement nicolas
il ya vu beaucoup de boîtes qui ne se la
pose plus cette question avec vous mais
c'est aussi au soutien
c'est à dire le jour où on vient me dire
votre risque crédit je vais pas le noter
de la même manière parce que j'ai fait
le lien mois entre le carbone et la
manière dont vous faites votre business
et je considère que si vous vous occupez
pas sérieusement de ce sujet avec une
méthode évidemment qui reste à définir
puisque c'est là c'est là où ça devient
grave et elle a indûment et l'endurance
c'est pareil imprime maintenant pour
être modulée en fonction de l'angle
carbone est elle en train d'être en
tournée en ontario depuis les assureurs
font gaffe à l'industrie du charbon par
exemple non mais prenez un prenez
quelqu'un qui par exemple qu'on sera à
des machines qui consomment beaucoup de
faire du rangement un entrepreneur de tp
ou bien un transporteur routier ou etc
si la personne qui lui finance ces
camions ou ces engins vient lui dire
pour usage que vous allez en faire vous
pourriez prendre un machin qui consomme
un peu moins un tout petit peu plus
petits etc
et si vous le faites je vous à baisse
d'un demi point le christ vous plaise ou
non mais si on a fini jean derrière
qu'elle soit vous posez sur marc
jancovici peut rien à voir je me la pose
tout le temps et comme vous êtes un
spécialiste vous allez avoir un élément
de réponse pourquoi dès qu'on dit écolo
on a l'impression que politiquement
c'est être à gauche voire même d'extrême
gauche c'est être conclu nucléaire avait
à tout une espèce d'imaginaire
intellectuelle à côté du mot écolo qui
amène à milieux politiques ou le lien ne
me crève pas les yeux loin d'être taquin
parce que dès que vous avez un plateau
télé où il est question d'écologie c'est
ces gens là qu'on invite moi je suis pas
restez sur la note non pas d'optimisme
béat dans lequel voudrait m'enfermer de
vie mais tout simplement de voir le
verre à moitié plein au lieu de le voir
à moitié vide mais je suis bien d'accord
qu'on est probablement même en dessous
du niveau moitié mais je pense qu'une
des grandes victoires aujourd'hui du
mouvement qui est en train de se faire
c'est que les écolos ont perdu
absolument le monopole du débat sur la
question environnementale et climatique
et que c'est une excellente nouvelle et
que du coup ils sont en train de
s'abîmer dans un tas d'autres débats
qu'on leur laisse bien volontiers c'est
pas tout à fait vrai mais on est en
train de vivre une transition et ce
plateau en offre une excellente
illustration
si harry faut que ces sujets-là s'invite
dans le débat économique de manière
sérieuse
j'espère qu'on a un petit peu près ce
matin mais mais mais c'est ça le sujet
parce que plus on le fait et moins du
coup il ya deux crédits effectivement du
côté des gens qui sont dans l'anti tous
et qui font pas de la gestion donc comme
qui compte après celui de lui je suis
prêt le jour il modifiera sa police au
léman clarisse posé aux environs de
mesures sociales faut pour est dans la
logique de marché de taux qu'on devrait
lui facturer l'idée qu'on vient de lui
et contre tout c'est le suivre on a fait
tous je suis d'accord le tarif et la
tonne de carbone et même peut-être la
tonne de matière grise
merci d'avoir été là donc jean marc
jancovici dormez tranquilles jusqu'en
2006 ont publié chez odile jacob
gilles legendre et ludovic subran on se
retrouve dès demain à 9 heures à suivre
intégral placement